I am an idiot this should come as a
surprise to no one but what is sometimes
a surprise is that I am also half Korean
this is probably news to so many of you
and I hate to break it to you like this
but yes I am half Korean half English
and half German American I'm an American
full of red meat brown sodas what I'm
learning Korean this is in Korea right
now you can tell by I'm in Korea just
trust me I could be in an underground
bunker right now no no no the difference
but I'm in Korea right now and I'm in
the offices of talk to me in Korean
which are the people behind this amazing
book right here which I didn't discover
until I got here I've been learning
Korean from my mom for the past two
years and I only just got these now and
they have advanced my learning
incredibly not saying my mom's a bad
teacher these books are made by the
wonderful Jana Sangh son singing funny
miss Samsung me would you come down into
the place I know it too and now I feel
can you confirm were in Korea we are in
Korea how else there's no way to prove
no we're in Korea maybe you can smell it
so I found these books a little bit ago
they've been a great help
but I've also brought someone who is
unbelievably angry that I'm learning
from anyone other than her my mother
[Music]
are we in Korea right now
are we win Sol Sol Sol my editor is
Portuguese he will have no idea how to
translate anything so lik sein good luck
we are in Seoul my pronunciation pretty
good right pretty good so it so you
didn't say Seoul oh yeah we also have
this child my cousin here who is way
stronger than he looks you may know him
if you follow me on Twitter he's that
kid that beats me up here's a video pin
beating me up here's another video of
him basically embarrassing me yeah so
this is Sam so you say hello okay so not
only is Seong stronger than me as
evidenced by this video is also smarter
than me and probably knows more English
than me so I wanted to set up kind of a
deathmatch showdown between these
different sunset names so I'm saying the
duty mm-hmm who is the better teacher I
am a terrible student so I need someone
to show that they're better and just so
you know if you say you're better than
my mom my entire audience will find you
yeah find me in what I can't promise
what they will do I can promise what
they won't do which is leave you happier
than when they found you okay you will
be not happy Hank okay on book ID z ng a
nucleon okay you will not be happy when
my it's fun yes you are better than my
mom but here's the thing I think you're
a better teacher than
oh I want to go through if you have an
idea of what you can teach me
and maybe them and maybe say on in
English what else can you say other than
hello hello my goal a lot of kill nobody
listen if you don't speak English I will
beat you up
okay and then there will be a video
proof that I'm actually stronger than
you yeah and I could win in a fight in
the end fight to the death
okay until one person dies yeah that's
scary that's not something that we
actually encourage but on markiplier
would encourage him with every video
okay you told me that you studied with
level 3 in bot level 4 it's a little bit
above where I was so I've been listening
to level 3 the reason talk to me in
Korean is great is because in addition
to great books they have a lot of free
resources and those are great for
getting you started and pushing you
towards like advancing your knowledge
with say books and stuff like that which
they have a lot of a lot of very good
books but also great places to start
with Korean so if you were interested in
Korean I'm not sponsored by them in any
way they are literally a great resource
yeah I only gave you a cup of water I
didn't even get that idea I walked in I
walked in and everyone just stood up and
just stared at me operate you water and
you refused right what did that was that
rude of me yeah I was hurt hurt a father
I see me out again
yeah we're not sponsoring you thank you
for stopping by voluntarily
[Music]
his undisclosed bunker that we're in no
I think you know pretty much everything
in this boat but I think you will want
to be able to use this really this
you're assuming a lot about there see I
was learning from my mom here and I
cannot guess yeah I agree
no your let me let me see if you can
already say person I like some you like
people okay that's good Eagle soon I
mean yeah Toyo this people like it a
person I like okay person
yeah people known Oh
sodomy honda really it you told me that
she's a great teacher and i didn't you
know
no I didn't know what you meant but I
would normally go to lengths you know to
hide eyes the dictionary for me to
conjugated to you know they modifying my
man but she just said comes before the
now because the little one have been
there been there done that
so I assume thing but I've got no
retention so I have to be reminded of
everything happens to I don't know
scoreboard point for mom stop barking
her face no no he doesn't speak a say on
to fight with me mm and even though I
lost chopped him in his neck destroying
his voice voice box
never gonna be able to be together all
right now let's continue hope it's okay
I will try to teach you some new stuff
and then if she likes it she will give
me the approval okay so you already know
a person then I like is Tuan and how do
you say so my like yeah except it
sounded like a song that is giving
advice to another whole internet what is
the basis of - ah ah ah ha - Hana - I
didn't do it nori
- ha ha I'm not a great any k-pop songs
that you like - one and kpop blu-ray my
god Matt bye bye red velvet I'm gonna do
that yeah my singing was just so good
they're gonna mistake it for the real
song okay you were just singing so
somebody who thinks is lieutenant Adam I
think you've got this already because
you already swear I swear I've whenever
I listen I my eyes shut down so it
doesn't matter where I'm looking if I'm
listening and it seems like I'm staring
off into space it either is because my a
DD kicked in and I am staring off into
space or I'm listening harder than
you've ever been so and I'm listening so
hard
listen perfect sorry I'm so into a goon
jalaja noon noon
a person that I like I love yes the
tricky thing is though in Koreans
hominins harem can be both directions
someone I love I love or somebody who
loves something else
oh so if you put like copy do computers
have an antenna it instantly becomes
somebody who loves my cards wanna set up
is somebody that arc likes dude he's
somebody that likes which is everybody
no one hates me captures now people are
disliking because you even said the word
don't you how you do works
listen there's now a bunch of people
that are going for the dislike button
which means that you people who are
loyal to me
the rider die fans need to hit that like
button as hard as you can because
they're gonna be people that are
fighting now and you gotta help me cuz
someone that's a minus one point for
y'all new to won the scoreboard is set
so you gotta help engage okay this is
how I teach myself okay cool Johanna's
Adam is someone whom either I like or
someone who likes something so if you
use car Mindy the name
I don't know what it was but I zoned out
this is the subjects name okay yes ah
this is its maker subset okay name
subject Johanna is from - ahaha
perpetual haha in Korea you can make
bourbon - entity vice versa by wrap up
tie and put neon in there okay and it
put grown-up the noun which is harem
person so ejected from perv - ah Hannon
Sarang so minty Quechua knows harem a
person who means you like but if you use
means each one and harem Lilly's object
are equal so you put after noun which is
it so Minzy Minzy don't want harem when
someone whom like minty means you got
one of them so the person who mean do
you like okay I think we need to work
with your mom on her Channel yeah it's
very good but I have to leave it up to
the fans decide who was the better
teacher in this scenario so hit that
like button if you think my mom was the
better - I don't take that dislike but
this is my humble opinion I heard his
teaching on I was his pronunciation and
his English is will off of mine I live
in America over 30 years today are many
for the first time I said have you lived
in America and he said never passing and
how you speak so well listen I started
on my own
you have caused my mother emotional
distress from your mere existence some
reason I'm
took a person but my brain in language
Department that's not working properly
and where did I get my stupid from I'm
hearing maybe you could look wrong but I
like talking often up like here against
the language Department I think she also
gave you a lot of confidence right yeah
I do obviously we can't make this in our
video about green lesson because you've
never spoken Korean this is math books
ahead where you need to start with
dragony yeah but one of the things I
want to say is learning Korean is very
difficult but getting started in Korean
is actually very easy because number one
is very easy for those of you who are
new to it it's the writing system the
only providing system in the world that
has been invented by one person yeah it
takes flowers to that yes exact that's
not an exaggeration you would learn it
in two hours that's how long it takes
and then once you do that you start to
learn the pronunciation rules you
starting to learn how these letters like
combined with each other how they're
like kind of flow together and then you
can get started with the language the
grammar is very different and it's hard
to get a grasp of like the particle
system and stuff like that that these
books spell it out really nicely and
I've only I bought them only halfway
through for a little bit and I've been
listening to this stuff here but it's a
it's really good stuff if you want to
learn a Korean I can say without a
shadow down unless you have a mother
that natively speaks Korean this
probably this is is this mom approved oh
[Music]
you can put that on a stamp on there and
I also like to add that your Korean is
really really good already and I think
that's also due to the fact that you
have confidence
whenever you say anything you know when
you've met me I was ready to say hello
to you and you said I know I say oh
that's amazing
most people will shy away they they know
so much but then they will only say it
this way so not afraid of making a
mistake
exactly just say whatever you learn
confidently and then everybody around
you will help
the lesson ears shout whatever you know
at the top of your lungs to anyone that
will listen to you walk him to a
department store and young I say yo I
think it doesn't matter if you say that
just shouting angrily as possible so the
real purposes of the video is not for me
to learn Korean it's for me to learn
Taekwondo and show you that I am
stronger than a small child I need a
small child say um come here I know I
say oh hello oh good okay so I'm gonna
beat you up oh ma tell say all right
[Music]
okay okay okay okay
chuff slowly just stop just stop
I don't want to hear that just up I
don't want to say just see you're
fighting in Crocs and you still I don't
know I decided to end the video like
this more Korean adventures to come soon
go to the talk to me in Korean calm to
start your learning Korean adventure Oh
[Music]